- [Tiffany] This is my friend
Laura, and she's 80 years old.
- [Laura] And this is my
friend Tiffany, and she is 26.
- [Tiffany] And we live
in a retirement community.
(upbeat violin music)
I'm a part of of the
Artist-in-Residence program
at Judson Manor,
which is a residential program where
young musicians get to live here rent-free
in exchange for performing
recitals and concerts.
When I tell people I live
in a retirement community,
I get a lot of mixed reactions.
Some people don't believe me,
other people think it's a wonderful idea.
- I had not been a part of
this community more than
two days
I was in the lobby and
they told me about Tiffany,
and I walked over and introduced myself,
and I said, "Do you like dogs?"
Oh, she loves dogs.
And Tiffany and I became friends,
we just formed a friendship.
We'll talk about art,
we talk about clothes.
I don't wear fashionable shoes anymore,
but Tiffany does, and we talk about shoes.
- Laura, to me, is like a grandma,
and also a friend, and a confidante.
I don't think the age difference is
something that I am
constantly thinking about,
or that I'm aware of.
You don't think, oh,
I'm having dinner with
this 100-year-old and this 90-year old,
I'm having dinner with my
friend Laura and Sarah.
In a way it is almost like
being in a college dorm
with the fact that there
are so many people here
from different places,
from different backgrounds.
It might be a little bit quieter
than a normal college dorm,
but I think we still
have just as much fun.
(gentle piano music)